[Música]
nosotros vamos a hablar ahora con
nuestro segundo invitado del día de un
tema también en que está también en
muchas ocasiones en no publicado en
medios de comunicación internacionales y
es todo lo que está pasando en Venezuela
a nivel social todos estos contrastes
que hay sobre todo en la ciudad de
Caracas la capital venezolana donde una
zona conocida como las Mercedes pues
está muy en boga últimamente porque ahí
se encuentra una tienda por
departamentos de lujo donde venden
marcas como Gucci también valenciaga y
otro tipo de marcas muy muy costosas de
alta costura también está un
concesionario de autos Ferrari todo esto
también tiene que ver con una
dolarización de facto del país desde
hace ya pues varios meses atrás A lo
mejor más de un año evidentemente y
también la inyección de capital por
parte pues de personas que necesitan
gastar el dinero
en Venezuela todo esto también
contrastado en un país por supuesto No
hay que negarlo No hay que ponerlo a un
lado con una crisis profunda personas a
que no tienen para poder comer para
poder pagar la canasta básica incluso
hay ahorita en este momento también
desde hace unos días protestas para pues
pedir aumento en los sectores públicos
saludamos entonces a nuestro segundo
invitado al día e hizo narciniega
sociólogo docente e investigador
presente del centro de estudios
agroalimentarios de Venezuela Gracias
Edison por estar con nosotros en directo
América de Francia 24 y Cómo podemos
darle esta lectura lo que estamos viendo
actualmente en Venezuela no una sociedad
que es difícil de entenderla en este
momento mucho dinero para unas personas
muy poco para otras
en esencia estamos en una de las
sociedades más desiguales de América
Latina podríamos decir que en Venezuela
pues existe o en la ciudad de Caracas
pues existe una especie de un pequeño
Mónaco y una especie de un pequeño
volumen apenas a 15 kilómetros de las
Mercedes podrías tú tener o tienes
comunidades en filas de mariche en las
que la población no es capaz de consumir
más de mil quinientas calorías por día
mientras en las Mercedes tienen las más
absoluta ostentación pero si vamos a los
grandes indicadores de Venezuela nos
vamos a dar cuenta que el pib Per cápita
del país es de apenas 2050 dólares y
también nos vamos a dar cuenta el pib
general de Venezuela no llega a los
50.000 millones de dólares al final lo
que está sucediendo en las Mercedes es
una gran ficción es una burbuja que no
es correlativa Al conjunto de
funcionamiento económico en Venezuela y
que responde la tentación mi opinión es
algo grosera de aparte de algunos
sectores económicos que ante la
imposibilidad de continuar haciendo uso
de sus recursos fuera del país producto
de los esquemas de sanciones que padecen
ellos pues se han visto obligados a
introducir esos recursos en la economía
nacional y Buscar esquemas para la
legitimarlo claro Hay también Edison una
dolarización de facto en Venezuela que
también pues está haciendo todo esto
posible pero obviamente uno viendo todo
esto desde afuera hasta donde es
sostenible esto en el tiempo no
evidentemente no es una moneda de curso
legal en el país es decir el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro no compra dólares a
Estados Unidos Entonces hasta cuándo
Esto va a ser sostenible para después
hablar un poco más de de la parte social
Mira el El Gran tema por la dolarización
es que se ha dolarizado toda la economía
privada pero no se no se ha dolarizado
la economía pública por la
particularidad económica correspondiente
al Estado los empleados públicos
venezolanos en promedio están ganando en
torno a 17 dólares y las cuentas
públicas apuntan a que el estado no
tiene capacidad de pagar Más allá de 40
dólares en promedio por trabajador lo
cual frente una canasta básica que
promedia los 480 dólares pues entonces
nos habla que el estado solo es capaz de
pagar una novena parte de lo que el
correspondería pagar por otro lado
tenemos el hecho que la dolarización en
Venezuela es tan imperfecta que en
Venezuela se registró en el año 2022 una
inflación en dólares es decir los
precios en dólares en Venezuela se
incrementaron 55% en el lapso de un año
nosotros no solo tenemos un altísimo
inflación en bolívares que tiene un alto
componente inercial sino que También
tenemos una altísima inflación en
dólares y es muy probable que en el mes
de febrero de repetirse los datos que se
registraron en el mes de diciembre en
este mes que va en curso pues Venezuela
regresa al fenómeno inflacionario esto
se nos está traduciendo también un
incremento de la vulnerabilidad
alimentaria los datos están apuntando a
que haya aproximadamente un tercio de la
población venezolana que está dentro de
la frontera del hambre y eso podría
expandirse ante la incapacidad de la
población que depende de los ingresos y
de las transferencias de dinero que hace
el estado venezolano de poder seguir
posteando la al menos la canasta
alimentaria de emergencia que está
valorada y cerca de 110 dólares
vamos a hablar ahora Edison de la parte
social que me llama muchísimo la
atención de lo que está ocurriendo en
este momento en Venezuela sobre todo
digamos poniendo por ejemplo esta zona
de la Mercedes pero pues evidentemente
menor escala también las Mercedes hay en
varios lugares del país en varias en
varias ciudades del país no cómo esto
juega en las sociedades que ahorita
están creciendo en Venezuela poniendo un
ejemplo un niño de diez doce años cuando
su prioridad a lo mejor sea comprarse un
Ferrari o comprarse una camisa Ferragamo
o algo un artículo de de lujo no de de
estas tiendas que las venden en
Venezuela inobiar la realidad del país
evidentemente un país que no funciona
como debería funcionar en normalmente no
Entonces cómo Qué daño le pudiera estar
produciendo todo esto a materia
aspiracional para la nueva generación
que está creciendo en Venezuela también
no sé si genera algún tipo de
insensibilidad por lo que le está
ocurriendo también a la mayoría de la
población venezolana
habría que decir que si en Venezuela los
estudios de inteligencia de Mercado
hablan en Venezuela hay unos dieciséis
millones de consumidores nominales de
esos 16 millones de consumidores
nominales esa el target o el bloque que
está asociado a fenómenos o a la oferta
de ventas que puede generar una zona
como las Mercedes son aproximadamente un
millón y medio es decir esa modelo
económico de altas tentación lo
corresponde a ese segmento de la
población ese segmento de la población
pues es bastante chico y pueden aspirar
a llevar una vida bastante holgada en el
país pero tenemos el resto de los
consumidores efectivos y el resto de la
población también inclusive los
consumidores en efectivos Entonces
tenemos un país roto tenemos por un lado
unas personas que pueden aspirar a
gastarse en comprarse un Mercedes vence
o hasta ir a un restaurante que está
guindado en una grúa en donde nada más
por montar desde cobro en 180 dólares y
luego tendrías que pagar el el la cuenta
de la comida al final tendrías un gran
un costo por persona acercar a los 320
dólares en restaurante aéreo Pero y por
otro lado tienes personas que están
suscribiendo con 25 dólares al mes
tienes esas dos realidades dentro de la
misma ciudad tienes esas dos realidades
dentro del mismo país tienes la realidad
de que mientras en el 20% más rico de
Venezuela
El plato de comida promedio tiene 50% de
proteínas de origen animal y puede estar
pesando cerca de un kilo 200 gramos en
el 20% más pobre de Venezuela El plato
de comida no llega a tener
15% de proteínas de origen animal y no
pesa más de 300 gramos es decir que es
un país donde los propios platos de
comida expresan una desigualdad extrema
tienes un país donde aspiracionalmente
no hay cohesión social donde esa
ausencia de cohesión social se nos viene
traduciendo en un creciente clima de
tensión y ansiedad social que va
impulsando un creciente clima también de
protestas ese clima de protesta nos hace
pensar que podríamos estar en presencia
en las próximas semanas de una
agudización de la conflictividad en
Venezuela debido a que no hay
posibilidad de seguir convocando a los
venezolanos al civismo el sismo No es
otra cosa que la capacidad de las
personas de sacrificarse en pro del
interés general del interés colectivo de
su sociedad ya los venezolanos la
inmensa mayoría asalariada de los
venezolanos no puede seguir esperando en
la promesa pública de que algún día nos
vamos a recuperar